there's like a subculture on Tick Tock
that's just so obsessed with the Stanley
Cup and what you put in it and the
flavored water is in the soda
concoctions and I was like I need this
this looks like it'll change my life and
it completely did I've gotten actually
so many of the people on my team and so
many of my friends on the Stanley grind
with me I did live in Utah for a while
and Utah is the land of like specialty
craft sodas this is like what they put
the sodas in so it's like Diet Coke and
like coconut creamer and like lemon
juice and like all of this fun stuff to
like doctor up your sodas I'm into that
I'm very into that it's really fun